they were the sweetest people you meet
and I know everyone in the community
could back me up on that that they would
always just go out of their way if
anyone needed anything I just saw the
end you're surrounded a me and yes oh
we're hanging out after because we had a
meeting we were organizing a health fair
together and the end user I've always
been so helpful with that and have been
like influential part of that event and
so me and you saw her hanging out and
she just always asked me how I'm doing
and whenever I have a problem she's just
there for me and she's like a true
friend like especially in my age you
don't find people who are that genuine
it was their entire family dabarkads and
the vasila is their entire family Machel
are just amazing people they lived as
Saints and they died as martyrs for us
hopefully this will make people realize
that Muslims are just innocent 23 21 and
19 year olds who didn't harm anyone and
then they'll see us for good people that
we are as the good people that you heard
the unreason were and changed their
opinion of us so no one else has to get
hurt
you